the Joe Rogan experience how that [ __ ]
did that happen that has a crazy time
you think about the the history of this
country that just two hundred years ago
we were in you know less we're in the
middle of a bitter war from the north
versus the South Americans fighting
Americans to the death big fields full
of dead people my dad was at one of the
fields
I forget which field it was but he said
you know it's one of those memorial
places in the south and he said the
feelings or something yeah you know what
it was Gettysburg and he said you feel
it he's like you feel sadness then yeah
so I get sound I know it sounds crazy
and he was saying I don't even believe
in that stuff but you feel it like
you're there you like oh yeah we've been
in a few memorials
a few memorials and a few big you know
like especially like military cemeteries
oh you just you know another one I felt
it like exactly what you're saying I
went to a historic part of Custer where
they lost the battle and I walk the
whole hill and everything you can feel
it there wow what is that do you think
there's like memory in places hell yeah
there is yeah it probably is right I
mean think there is it's probably an
instinctive reason why people don't want
to live in a house where someone was
murdered yeah I don't want to live there
I don't want to live there okay like um
there's a house that Jon Benet Ramsey
was killed in in Colorado they can't
sell that [ __ ] house
dude I live there nine years ago eight
years ago somewhere like that nine years
ago and they were selling it then they
still can't sell it it's a beautiful
house it's in a really nice neighborhood
can't sell it they have to change the
name of the street they change the name
of the street still can't sell it I'm
not kidding
they just can't sell it has it does it
have like historical everybody's
terrible sightings and stuff or was it
just killing just the killing and the
the hold the darkness all behind it I
mean that was one just was it wasn't
just a little girl died but there's all
this darkness
she was sexually active there was
something going like someone was
probably molesting her someone in the
family or someone else who knows they
think some of the family might have
killed her they don't know who it was
it's never been solved no one's ever
been tried it's a dark
yeah I'm not moving there [ __ ] that they
can keep that I think I should level
that thing to the ground and maybe even
do something with the ground Ernie that
scoop all that [ __ ] out put some new
dirt and yeah I'm not kidding I'm not
kidding like that might be the only way
who are you gonna throw that mojo on
though you got to put that dirt you got
to put that dirt somewhere yeah he's
worthy of taking it right where would
you put that dirt you have to exercise
it you'd have to build like the most
awesome Park for kids like you'd have to
turn that house into something you're
positive I don't want to do anything for
kids there for sure that would be bad
taste but you could always take that big
scoop and kind of put it in a freak
party desert or something where people
that like ghosts and crap can go out
there and play in it or camp on it
everybody likes a little kid ghosts you
want like some old man ghosts can tell
you secrets you think you've ever seen
no I do not have you ever experienced
something that was like super creepy do
you know what a couple of my friends at
The Comedy Store have claimed to have
seen ghosts and claimed to have seen
things and I with many of my friends
that work there and comics and stuff
we've gone upstairs to the belly room in
the dark just freaked ourselves out
stoned out of our mind I feel it we
gotta go what you go into the main room
at night like give me a hug hold me ahh
I'm scared it's a it's a weird place man
people for sure have been murdered there
it was a Bugsy Siegel's nightclub in the
nineteen what wasn't authorities or 40s
or some [ __ ]
it was Ciro's nightclub yeah there's
definitely some mojo there yeah for sure
[Applause]